[MUSIC]
It's now my, my, my pleasure and my honor
to introduce today's speaker and my
colleague Hayagreeva Rao.
Hayagreeva is the Ethel McBean professor
of organizational behavior and human
resources.
Here at the GSB he's also a professor
of sociology at the schools of humanity
and science.
He's also the academic director of a
fantastic online program.
Our first online program the Stanford
innovation and entrepreneurship program.
This is a program that we built jointly
with out engineering school.
It has 12 modules, they built half a dozen
we built half a dozen.
And it's available online to to people who
who don't have the
time or the ability to attend one of our
in person classes.
And the attraction we've gotten from it
has, has
significantly exceeded actually what
we've, what we have planned, so.
I, I thank Hagi for his leadership in
that.
He's also the corrector of the custom
focus innovations executive
program and the corrector of the advanced
leadership program.
For asian American Executives.
He has been working on on on, on the
christian
of scaling together with Bob Sutton, he
has A book
on the topic, which I'm sure he's going to
tell
you about, and I think you're in for a
real treat.
It's been a best seller, it's one of the
top 10 books listed by Forbes and the
Washington Post.
Please join me in giving a warm welcome to
Huggie Ralph.
>> [SOUND].
>> Good evening everybody.
Let me begin by first saying thank you
certainly on behalf of my faculty,
colleagues it's
just impressive to see so many out of
staters and so many people from overseas
as well.
Coming here your affection for the GSP, of
course matters a lot to
us, because we can, of course, continue to
build on our traditions of excellence.
And do and, and you know get to greater
heights.
So I'm just actually begin this talk with
a little bit of a confession.
I finished business school in India in
1980.
And the astonishing thing was as I was
finishing business school in India the
textbooks that
we actually followed I think the one in
finance, if I recall, was by Jim Vanhorne.
If you can believe it.
You know the one in accounting was by
Chuck Horngren.
And we even had Jeff Pfeffer's A book on
the external control of organizations.
And in 1980 when I graduated I had no idea
that
all of them would eventually turn out to
be my colleagues.
It is truly sort of extraordinary in that
sense.
And the other funny thing was in 1981 Tom
Peters an alum of the GSB, of course,
wrote a remarkable book called In search
of excellence and if
at that time if you had told me I would
have actually written a
book on excellence I would have said look
you are out of your mind.
But the amazing thing is that we did and
Tom has actually been a great supporter.
And we're all very grateful to him.
The books done well as Garth mentioned.
You know, it's nice to know sort to be on
the Wall street Journal
best seller list or whatever, but really,
what touches your heart is we did a
little thing on NPR and there was this
little There was this lady from
Rugle Georgia who actually emailed me and
said, you know, I heard you on NPR.
I ran down and bought the book.
And we've created a little learning group
in
rural Georgia to scale excellence in our
schools, there.
That sort of really melted my heart, you
know?
And the reason it melted my heart is, my
mom was a high school math teacher.
You know.
She was, I guess, a tiger mom before
that, that particular label kinda got
constructed or invented.
So, what I'm gonna do is you know, share a
few ideas in the hope that we can have a
conversation.
I'd like to leave a bunch of time aside
for questions.
In many ways this book and this whole
adventure with Bob Sutton would never have
been possible.
Without you know a program that
[INAUDIBLE]
to call the customer focus innovation
program.
So what we do is we get 60 people, and the
morning is all what we call clean models,
social science, and the afternoon is all
about dirty hands, or design thinking.
And the participants love it, so they come
in the morning, and they come in on
Sunday.
Mornings you know, they're being exposed
to
social science and then, every afternoon,
they have
to solve an, a problem, a challenge, if
you will, for some company or the other.
And, seven years ago, we were doing that
with JetBlue.
And, in fact the participants did some
pretty amazing sort of things.
You know, you go and, you know, all the
design thinking ideas that many of you I'm
sure, are.
Familiar with.
So, at the end of the program, one of the
participants asked
us, how do I take this back and scale it
in my company?
So, I gave an answer, and my colleague Bob
gave an
answer, and that evening as we were
debriefing in Menlo Park,
we live there, over a nice glass of Pinot
Noir you
know, I said, Bob, what did you think of
your answer?
And he said, what do you think of yours?
And I said mine was truly sad, I said.
It was really bad, you know.
And I'm very disturbed about it because I
just couldn't say anything that really
was, you know, interesting or challenging,
or provocative or what have you.
So I asked Bob, what do you think, Bob?
And Bob says, mine sucked too.
[LAUGH]
And so, you know, few more glasses later
so we, we said, what are we gonna do about
it?
And you know, we did something that
Stanford professors do you know, with.
Great support and encouragement from
everybody.
And that is, if you really don't
know something, and you're quite ignorant
about it,
the best thing to do is to actually dream
up a course and offer it.
[LAUGH]
So, when you dream up a course and offer
it, a couple of things happen.
The first thing is, you are super
motivated, cuz you're clueless.
You have to read a lot, you've gotta put
together something.
And the students they, you know, they
sense your excitement and your
curiosity, they kind of engage with you
and they teach you a lot.
And, so we were kind of thinking, how
do we teach people about how to scale
something?
And Bob and I thought, let's give them a
challenging, hard problem.
So, we had 60 students, we could have
gotten more but we capped it at 60.
30 from engineering and 30 from GSB.
And then we put them into teams and
randomly assigned dorms and
spokes team on the Stanford campus to each
of these student teams.
And we give them one scaling challenge.
Scale to use of bicycle helmets by
bicyclists on Stanford campus.
It's a very hard thing to do by the way.
because, you know, there's memory loss and
particularly the undergrads are fully
pursuant of their immortality and
invincibility
[LAUGH] and it was very, very hard.
But the students came up with like,
amazing ideas.
You know, so one team I remember they were
given
EV, they scandled a village with these you
know, grad students.
And so they kinda went to the grad
students and try to persuade them
and facts and, you know, here's what
happens when you fall of a bike.
None of these things worked.
And finally these people said wait a
minute.
We really ought a go to the elementary
school on the Stanford campus.
Because a lot of the kids of grad students
actually go there.
Let's actually organize a campaign amongst
these kids.
And what they did was, they actually got
the kids to
write little notes for their parents,
saying hey, wear a helmet.
It was amazing.
And by the way, the way we graded the
course was, we knew what the base rate
of helmet usage was, so the more you
moved the needle, the better the grade,
you know?
Which caused some interesting challenges,
I might add.
[LAUGH] And so there was another team that
went to the men's soccer, team.
So, they told him look, you know, if you
fall off a bike, bad things can happen,
you know, you're telling the men's soccer
team,
they just said give me a break, you know.
But, then, they quickly realized, wait a
minute, we need to communicate this to
them
in an interesting way, and they came
with the idea of a watermelon smashing
competition.
So they would go there, and tell these
people after they dropped
a water melon, that's your brain when you
fall off a bike.
And people said, really.
And they said, you know, you may think
you're immortal but if
that happens to you, think of what's gonna
happen to your team.
And that got the attention of the men's
soccer team.
And very quickly you know, their penalty
if you will, if.
Any of the men's soccer team didn't wear a
bike helmet, they'd actually fling the
watermelon at the kid.
So, you know, that kind of deviant
behavior got punished.
It sort of spread for awhile.
And the second year we actually did a
project with the MBAs and the engineers
again, and
this time they were actually working with
front
line engineers and soldiers and that kind
of stuff.
It's unbelievable.
I mean when you sort of see we actually
had a general in
the rapid deployment force who came to us
and said hey can they help.
And we said oh, what a great problem.
And so we once again told our students to
go figure these things out.
And the sorts of things they came up with
were, like, simple but profound too.
One, just one example.
[COUGH]
So soldiers, of course, get redeployed,
and
you get rotated and you have replacements.
And you have interesting transfer of
knowledge problem.
How do you transfer knowledge from
outgoing cohort of soldiers.
To an incoming cohort.
The U.S Army's modus operandi is, you
actually have a
two hundred item questionnaire that you
have to fill out.
And, you can imagine what people are going
to do
when you give a two hundred item
questionnaire and that's
given to you right after you land on the
air
base in the U.S. when you've come back
from Kandahar.
You know, the response rate is abysmally
low.
So, there's just no way you're going to
get anything.
Plus it goes to some place in the
Pentagon.
They do some statistical analyses and they
don't turn out to be much either.
So our kids actually thought about for
awhile and they came up with like a,
one interesting idea that they came up
with for example was a look, why don't we.
Ask each soldier.
Look, can you take ten minutes to talk to
someone who is going to replace you.
Tell them three stories that actually are
interesting examples of your experience.
And if you spend ten minutes, we'll make
sure you get
half an hour more web access when you talk
to your family.
But, by the way, it's a very high powered
incentive, as you can image.
Web access is a very scarce resource, you
give them half an hour, and you
give these stories, and it's amazing when
these
people would tell stories to the incoming
soldiers.
What they were doing is they were actually
giving way
more data can, than can be accommodated by
a regression model.
You know you sort of say you know, sunny
days, sun
on the arise, the enemies in the hills or
what ever.
Just look at the number of variables that
are being incorporated in that story.
And it is very officially packaged.
So the army is actually trying it out.
So any way after many years of trying it
out we sort of thought you know.
We've actually learned, and we interviewed
a number of people
we wrote case studies, we did a bunch of
things.
So six years after the original question,
we actually thought okay let's write this
book.
And first a word about excellence.
You know, we could debate this to what
excellence is you know.
Plato says this or Socrates says this.
If your interested in eastern philosophy
the Gita says this.
But Bob and i are Social scientist and for
us excellence simply mean
people do the right job even when nobody
is looking over your shoulder.
That's what excellence is.
Because when you need people to monitor
others executing a task.
That's not excellence.
You know, for every ten people whom
you hire, you can't have three cops
monitoring.
There is no way you can scale if you do
that.
Cuz it's just you know, going to be huge
in bureaucratic and expenses.
So what's the problem of excellence?
There are two dimensions to the problem.
On the one hand.
You, if you're in a large corporation, or
even a
small one, you might have a pocket of
goodness, somewhere.
And what your challenge as a manager is,
or as an executive or
leader is, is how do I actually construct
a dominant chain of goodness?
How do I spread goodness from one place to
the others?
The challenge is when you do that you have
voltage loss.
This dilution.
There's kind of another dimension of
scaling up accidents and that is if you're
a small organization and as you're adding
people how do you actually scale up
accidents.
So, you know, wonders if you will
horizontal or cross
divisional or cross business unit, the
others, kinda, much more temporal.
There's also a little problem and the
little problem is, the larger an
organization gets, the more likely are
smart
people, inside the organization, to become
dumber.
And I don't say this to be coy.
And what I mean by beep smart people
becoming dumber is, I don't mean to
imply, obviously, that they become stupid,
but I
certainly mean to imply that they become
silent.
And that's the problem in a large
organization.
If they become silent.
You're basically in trouble.
So lots of examples of scaling you know,
a lovely little start up called Pulse, you
know.
They would always, they were two Stanford
grads, and they would call us
and say, we have a scaling problem, I'd
say like, what kind of problem?
There's just the two of us, we've hired
four more people, we have scaling problem.
I'm like, you guys are all working in one
room, how could that be a scaling problem?
But sure enough you realize they needed
to coordinate, they needed to set a
communicate.
And on the other extreme, you have
the institute for health improvement in
Cambridge.
They want to reduce debts caused by
preventable medical errors.
100,000 people a year die.
How do you do that when you don't have
cloud, when you don't have the quality?
When you don't have resources, and you
have 3,500 hospitals?
So that gives you if you will, the breadth
of the.
Scaling challenge.
So, the, the main sort of point I wanna I
'd suggest is.
Scaling up is deceptively easy but
screwing up is easier.
And the term, the scientific term Bob and
I use is, we call it a clusterfug.
And we can't of course use the actual
word.
And so what we did was we,
suddenly remembered, wait a minute, Norman
Mailer wrote
about fug successfully, and so we thought
let's
actually exploit this literally lineage of
the term,
so we called it clusterfug, and writing
the case as we speak, On the Navy Seals,
yeah I know, can you imagine a guy like me
riding a case on Navy Seals.
I know, even I've chuckled about the
absurdity of this.
So, I spend [INAUDIBLE] we actually have
two
amazing students who are helping me write
this case.
Carter [UNKNOWN], who's a Navy Seal
himself,
and Gib Lopez, who's actually an MBA also.
Both of them are helping me write this
case, and Carter and I went and.
Spent a chunk of time at Coronado.
In, but I was with the Navy Seal
commander.
You know they use a lot of abbreviations.
And there was one abbreviation that kind
of baffled me.
They called it PFM.
And after awhile I sort of had pretty good
idea of what the F stood for.
I'm sure all of you know that.
It was the P and the M that I was actually
utterly befuddled by.
And later when I asked the commanding
officer, I said what is PFM?
He said, pure, you of course know what the
f is, and the m, of course, means madness.
He said, that's what happens to us when we
try and scale sometimes, PFM.
Now, if you really look at, 30 years of
social
psychology, why is it that scaling ends up
in a clusterfug?
And this could be any decision.
New product, new technology
implementation, an acquisition, expansion
overseas, whatever the articulation or
realization of scaling.
It turns into a clusterfug because of
three things.
The first is.
Sense of illusion.
You actually have illusion because the
smart people have become silent.
You're not getting any feedback and it's
kind of like an echo chamber.
impatience.
Since you don't get feedback, you get
impatient, and then of course,
you have the smart people becoming silent,
the incompetent are the only ones
you rely on, and so when you put the three
of them
together, you get a trifecta, and you have
a spectacular kind of clusterfug.
And you can quickly see, actually, many
organizations, teams
actually taking the off-ramp to a
clusterfug pretty quickly.
Now, you know, what do you do?
So, I love reading history.
The Greek historian Herodotus says.
The Persians had an interesting decision
protocol to prevent
illusion, impatience, and incompetence,
and apparently what they would do
is, they would debate an issue drunk one
day and
the next day, they would re-debate the
same issue sober.
[LAUGH] Now, you might ask, what is the
value of such a decision protocol, and,
put simply, when people are drunk, they
put a lot of information on the table.
[LAUGH] but their ability to derive a
conclusion is debatable.
[LAUGH]
But, on the other hand if you're sober
people are strategic.
So they don't put a lot of information on
the table.
However even from the thinnest [UNKNOWN].
You can certainly construct an influence
if you will.
Now, our recommendation is not that you
follow what the Persians did.
Which is, you know, debate an issue drunk
and, you know,
then rebate it sober the next day, one of
the things we
started to talk about in the book is To
actually rely
on something called a pre-mortem, which is
the opposite of a post-mortem.
So, for instance, if the six of you were
in the
company and you were thinking of, like,
expansion, or IPU, or whatever
the decision outcome, I would randomly
assign three people to the failure
condition and say, imagine the event has
occurred, engage in time travel.
And then write a story of how that failure
happened.
Write it just in one page.
Remember it has to be a story not a list,
and the three people have
to write that anonymously and
independently cuz
if you, they collaborate, you'll have
correlated error.
So on the other side, same thing, you give
them, of course,.
The scenario of success.
Imagine the thing has succeeded.
Write a story of how that succeeded.
And, what is amazing is, when you get
these stories.
It is incredible what [INAUDIBLE] you
know?
When you write, when people write a story.
What they're doing is, they're actually
giving you, if you will.
You know, a state transition model.
You have various transition points, you
actually
can see the downward spiral of a debacle,
you can see the upward spiral of success,
and then you can quickly sort of debug.
By way of example let me illustrate, I
just recently did
a version of this with the leadership of
the Stanford Medical School.
They really wanna go big guns, create
something called.
Stanford medicine, where basic science has
to actually work with
the clinical hospitals.
And then, of course, the clinical
investigators
and you gotta work with the hospitals.
It's amazing the stories of failure people
wrote.
You know?
One person knew about side-effects, they
actually sent it as
a PDF file, but their electronic patient
records don't accept PDFs.
So the person who knew about
the side-effects, sadly told this to
everybody.
But nobody knew that.
Another person said, "Oh my God, we don't
have nurses to run these trials."
.
Another person would say wait a minute.
You know, we the hospital is taking care
of somebody in a trial.
This person doesn't know the basic signs.
They've misdiagnosed the cause of failure.
You have an action of a lawsuit.
So things like this when they were
actually put on the
table the very smart people, of course, in
the medical school faculty.
They quickly said, "Oh my God, we've
really got to get this going."
And very quickly they actually thought of
lots of possibilities
and began to put a lot of checks in
measure.
So just an example, so, think of.
Premortems if you will, the contemporary
equivalent to what the Persians kinda do.
So, what's the core message?
Why is it people take the off-ramp to a
clusterfuck?
And the answer is, usually when you ask
people what is
scaling, they invariably think of it in
terms of footprint-related metrics.
And, you know, it's perfectly sensible.
They're very important.
But the catch is.
If you ask people what's desirable social
psychology tells us
they actually think about this in a very
abstract way.
That's why they love the metrics.
You know, so many customers, so many this,
so many that, et cetera.
They're not really thinking about the
mindset.
The mindset is actually what allows the
footprint to survive and thrive.
One example, people really thinking about
the mindset.
We recently had founders of a company
called [UNKNOWN] they do
mapping software,they got acquired by
Google for a couple of billion.
And he was actually in class and he was
giving a fascinating example
of focusing really on the mindset, and
[INAUDIBLE] a number of other important
truths.
So they get 30 million you know, you,in an
earlier phase of the
revolution, they get 30 million dollars,
and the [UNKNOWN] are telling them,
"scale!"
you got 100 people, hire 400 more.
And the employees also expect head count
to go
up, the company to grow, you know, all
these things.
And the founders start to think about it,
and they thought about it, and then after.
They made a decision and then they called
all the
employees of the firm, and they announced
a hiring freeze.
People were stunned.
The employees said, are you out of your
mind, we just got 30 million dollars,
they're telling
you to scale, you know, is this a vote of
no confidence in the future of the firm?
Why a hiring freeze now?
It seems insane.
And the founders stood up and said look,
we had 100 people
we're gonna hire 400 smart people, all of
them have great ideas.
The problem is when you hire 400 smart
people and
they come to you, I have to say no 400
times.
Because we have to focus.
We can't just kind of get everybody's idea
into the mix, I've got to say no.
And I don't want to create 400 demotivated
people in one fell swoop.
And he said, the smart people that we
hire, they're smart, but they're also over
confident.
They think they can hit the ground running
on day one.
They can't.
They need to take three weeks to get
ready.
If I hire 400 people in one step, I've
actually altered dramatically the ratio of
unproductive to productive people.
And then what am I going to do as a CEO?
I'm going to spend time thinking about
how to make the produ, unproductive people
productive.
And I don't want to do that.
The real number we need to move is one
metric,
and that is, the three month user re user
retention metric.
We have users, there's a lot of churn, and
the real test of our
ability is, how many of them do we retain
over a three month period?
And so, one of the employees then said,
well, what's my job?
And you know he said, well, your job is
simple.
In fact, the job of everyone of us, is
very simple.
Everyday, we've got to ask, what did I do
today, to move that number?
Think about it.
And this story is also particularly
resonant with me, because
what it sorta [INAUDIBLE] to you is,
scaling is actually about.
When you scale an organization, you really
got to figure
out that it not just mindless addition,
it's actually smart subtraction.
In fact, when you're in the business of
scaling
excellence, you really are like a race car
driver.
You've got to figure out when to
accelerate but,
also, when to break and when to change the
gears.
And that's what they figured out.
And of course the company succeeded
subsequently.
And you quickly realize if people
mindlessly and individuals,
you're definitely taking the on ramp to a
clusterfug.
So, you know, I'm going to sorta of move
on.
And the problem of course with scaling is
if you don't do this well it's dilution.
Here's a confessional, a little memo from
Howard Schultz of Starbucks saying as we
move from 13 hundred to 13 thousand, we of
course lost sight of the customer.
And the constant is, in all the excellent
organizations we
visited, the executives invariably see the
glass as half empty.
And nowhere did we find somebody who sorta
says you know, we're doing great and you
know.
you, you just don't find that at all, they
all assume, my God, we
gotta do all these things all the
time, and that's kind of that relentless
restlessness.
So, I'm gonna give you a couple of big
lessons, maybe a choice
point or two, and a quick overview of some
of the main principles.
We, obviously won't be able to dive in too
deep, because
we, we, we end at 6:15, and I wanna make
sure.
There's some time for Q and A.
So one of the big lessons is scaling up
excellence isn't just an air war.
It's actually a ground war.
So what are the characteristics of an air
war?
When you think of an air war what do you
think about?
What's that?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> High level.
Abstract.
No details.
Absolutely.
What else?
Sorry, top down absolutely.
Huh?
>> collateral damage.
>> Collateral damage.
>> Uh,indeed collateral damage can
actually be
very high there's a fascinating historic
account
of the British bombing of Germany and they
found out that what is it?
[LAUGH] Twenty percent of the ordnance
landed
within five miles of the intended target.
[LAUGH] Yeah, the rest of it was like all
over the place.
That tells you something about collateral
damage.
What about a ground war?
Were [CROSSTALK] very personal?
What else?
>> More intense?
>> More intense.
>> Actual engagement.
So, when we go to companies, you can
quickly find out who is thinking about.
And in thinking in just an air war is not
enough.
I'm not saying air wars are bad obviously
you need a little bit of both.
But what you want to think about is you
really want to focus on the ground war.
And the reason is the following, because
remember when
you think air war, you're only thinking
very abstractly.
When you thinking ground war you're
thinking very, very concretely.
So for us the compelling distinction we
found is when I go to companies I ask
people hey how do you think you need to
get all these people to do something?
And the people who are in an air
war mode instantly leap to incentive based
reasoning.
We just need to figure out how to reward
them if they do or punish them if they
don't.
That's is that's all we need to do.
But the people who think of it in a ground
war term, they
actually sort of think, you know,
motivation
isn't the problem, tools are the problem.
The question is what kinda tools can we
give these people to make them succeed.
Very, very different.
So, I'll give you a little illustration of
how powerfully somebody thought of a
ground war literally.
In the context of a war and that was a
general called Matthew Ridgeway.
Now this was actually in the Korean War,
which is
for some strange reason not as you know,
given the kind
of attention, because some of the most
brilliant acts of
leadership really in the 20th century
occurred, in the, Korean War.
So imagine.
You know, [UNKNOWN] is there in Tokyo and
you know, he's
consumed by sensible delusion and delusion
and then Truman fires him.
And you're Ridgeway.
You're 42 years old.
You've never fought in Korea.
You're in charge of like 500,000 men.
Who simply being beaten, bruised,
battered,
basically by the Chinese first army.
You can't go and get YouTube's.
You can't give people a speech and say
jeez let's
kinda go and do something, you can't do
all that.
But look at what Ridgeway does.
The first thing he does is, he actually,
you know, he says.
I, I need to understand the topography, of
Korea.
So he goes to on a bomber and there's a
navigator and he tells the navigator can I
take your seat?
I want to see what the topography
is.
And he realizes oh my God, you know, lots
of hills and ridges and rivers and then he
meets these regimental commanders and he
says do you
know the name of the river close by to
you?
I said, do you know how the deep the water
is?
No.
You're fired, because you're putting
people in harm's way, you have no idea.
Apparently what the Pentagon had done is,
there were a lot of people
in the Pentagon who apparently weren't
given leadership opportunities in World
War Two.
They moved a lot of files and somebody
thought, you know.
We really need to kind of give them
leadership
opportunities so let's send them to Korea
as regimental commanders.
When the heaviest thing you've moved if a
file between two desks,
it's not exactly the right kind of person
to send to Korea.
And so the things that he sorta does to
give you a sense, no speeches, none of
these things.
But when he travels, no fighter escort,
most shot at General, in the 20th Century.
He says, my men are getting shot.
Why do I need a fighter escort?
Every time he goes and visits troops, it's
the cold Korean winter.
The only thing he has in his Jeep, ample
supply of gloves.
He gives gloves to soldiers and say, you
can hold your carbine.
So he goes to a forward operating post.
And he looks at a map.
And, you know, blue pins US, and red
communist forces.
So if you're Ridgeway.
You got 20 men in the room.
What's the question you're going to ask?
What's the diagnostic question you're
going to ask?
Imagine.
It's clear.
You know where the US forces are, where
the Communist forces are.
There are 20 men sitting there.
You're the general.
What's the, if you had one question to ask
to
diagnose what is going on, what would that
question be?
Hm?
Come on, somebody take a guess.
Come on.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> What do you need, that's good.
Which direction, that's good.
What else?
Wind.
How many people?
They're all very legitimate questions, but
the question he asks is.
How old is the information on which the
pen positions are based on?
And the men look at him and say, they're
15 days old.
What does that tell you?
Obviously, it's obsolete.
But it also tells you the men are afraid.
They don't want to go on a foot patrol.
Because they're afraid of getting
ambushed.
That's the reason you're not getting high
quality information.
And, that's when he tells people, look.
I need information that's three hours
fresh, we're going to
support you in this way, we're going to do
this, etcetera.
And, it's these same people who were
refusing to go, as
it were, on a foot patrol, the very same
people push.
The Chinese and not going in Communist
forces to the 36th Parallel.
There's actually a lovely story of a crazy
Marine General
whose unit is surrounded on all sides and
the men
tell him, the enemy is in front of us,
behind
us, to the left, to the right, what do we
do?
And this guy is slightly maniacal, so he
says, wonderful.
They've got nowhere to run.
[LAUGH]
You've gotta be crazy to think like that.
They actually punched through the
corridor.
So here's you know, this is what one
McKinsey consultant told us, the real
thing about the
ground war is, you gotta get a thousand
people
to move one foot forward at the same time.
In an air war, obviously, one person can
go a thousand feet forward.
So, the second thing is, scaling is a lot
about felt accountability.
Everybody talks of people feeling a sense
of ownership, and that's true.
You certainly need to feel you own the
place.
But if that's the only thing you do, that
can be dangerous.
You can quickly begin to think of
yourself.
It can get very swiftly egocentric.
And so what we find out about felt
accountability is you really need not only
the
feeling that you own the place, but you
also need the feeling the place owns you.
So you need actually the pull of
obligation, and then the push of
committment.
Both of those are needed.
And in the, one of the SCPs, there are a
couple of SCPers sitting here as well.
I was actually talking about this
interesting case study.
Anybody remembers this?
What's the hotel on the, what's the
building on the left?
I gave the game away by.
The Taj, exactly.
November 26 you had terrorists attacking
the hotel.
And, you know?
You had employees like these young ladies
on the left, doing things.
And, what's amazing is, you know?
When you have a terrorist attack, what do
you expect employees to do?
Head for the exit, cuz they know where the
exits are.
And that day there was no command and
control, the general
manager is rushing in from somewhere, can
only get to the lobby.
His family is being consumed by fire in
the 35th or the 36th floor.
Nobody's giving orders, nothing,
everything is in disarray.
Well, what was amazing is young ladies
like this who
were actually overseeing the reception for
the outgoing CEO of Unilever.
You know, in a conference room quickly
barricaded the room, made
sure that people were hydrated, the wives
were separated from the husbands.
Cooks escorted people down the stairs.
A lot of cooks lost their lives.
Because they gave their bodies as shields.
And later, when they asked some of these
employees, you guys were heroic.
They said no, we actually were doing our
job.
What's their job?
Their job actually is not to be an
ambassador of the Taj
to a customer, but to actually be an
advocate of the customer.
The Taj actually hires very carefully,
though.
You obviously can't do that in the United
States for legal reasons.
But one of the things they do is the never
hire people who are usually from the major
cities of India.
They always hire people who are from the
smaller cities of India.
Because the tradition of [INAUDIBLE] being
god is actually quite vibrant.
In the bigger cities, modernization has
actually
kind of assaulted all of those norms.
They do a whole bunch of other things.
As I was in this SEP class, talking about,
there's one of these executives made a
very sensible point.
And he said, Professor Robert, surely this
is a case of crisis.
You obviously expect your employees to
rally around this.
You know, isn't the real test what the Taj
does every day?
And I was about to say something.
We actually had another participant who
was a
senior executive at [INAUDIBLE] guy called
John Thomas.
He said, let me tell you about my
experience.
He said, I flew with my wife and three
year old to India.
Jet lag tired, the kid's crying, we're all
ornery,
the Taj sends a car to pick us up, on
route the baby is crying and I'm thinking,
oh, my
God, we gotta go through checking,
check-in delay and everything.
They come to the Taj and somebody meets
them and says, you've already been checked
in.
They take them to the room.
They open the doors and you know there's a
little flask
of milk and a bunch of cookies for the
three year old.
So John looks at them and says, how did
you know?
And the guy says, when you got in the car
your baby was
crying, the driver called the front desk
and said, baby on board, jet lagged.
Expedite.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now isn't that an amazing case of
accountability, felt accountability?
That's what felt accountability is.
And by the way, the driver isn't an
employee of the Taj, but a contractual
individual.
So here's this one woman called Fifi.
And when we did a study of Wyeth.
You know the one of the Wyatt plants, what
did they do?
They actually thought of
equipment changes as breaks.
So, mentally, when you categorize
something as a break, you're kind of
like, loose and easy, and you don't,
there's no sense of urgency.
But these people sort of said "wait a
minute, it's not a
break" that we've got organize ourselves
as though it's a pit stop.
Just that person and her team members and
look at
sort of what they did, in terms of, you
know,
not just the number of syringe production,
but how they
cut down the changeover time and the like
and so forth.
He's a quick example of a United Pilot.
Saying I used to do all these things.
And now, what do I do?
I gave up.
And I'm an Eagle Scout, and I'm an
entrepreneur.
So I'm gonna be very quick here, and talk
about a couple of ideas.
So, the most important choice point is
when you scale.
Do you want more, or do you want them to
be better?
So that's kind of one important choice
point.
The second choice point is, and this is
the
one I want to spend a little more time on.
Do you want to be a Catholic, or do you
want to be a Buddhist?
I went to Jesuit school in India.
I actually meditated and extracted from
St. Francis of Asisi every morning.
So, you know, even though I was born a
Hindu.
So, you know, certainly Jesuit education
has an enormous imprint on you.
But what do we mean by Catholic versus
Buddhist?
See, if you're a Catholic, it's like
you're, like In-N-Out Burger.
You've got a specific design or like
Intel's Copy Exactly model.
But, if you're a Buddhist, what you do is,
you don't allow a thousand flowers
to bloom but you give them good guard
rails, in the form of principles or
protocols.
When you can actually allow for local
realization.
And one of the heroes in our book is Chip
Connelly, who
actually just has joined Arab B and B as
their customer relations person.
He used to own a chain of hotels called
Joie de Vivre.
That he sold.
And then all over the place, like the
Phoenix Hotel to the Rex
Hotel, and their range in price from 100
bucks a night to 700 bucks.
So when we are asked, Chip, how do we
go about building these hotels, look at
his Buddhist protocol.
He asks his employees, any time you come
to me with a request
for funds to start a new hotel, you need
to answer four questions.
Question one: What magazine does your
customer read?
If it's The New Yorker, I know exactly who
they are.
You don't need to tell me anything else.
Question two: What are the five adjectives
you would use to describe the experience?
So, if it's The New Yorker, is
sophisticated one of the adjectives, for
example?
If that's indeed an adjective, how will
the customer
quickly sense that through his or her five
senses?
Nobody needs to tell the person this is a
sophisticated place.
You walk in, you instantly know, you know?
Maybe they're playing a particular kind of
music, through a sense
of ear, or you see the bar's like a
library, whatever.
And the next question is, how do
the employees know this through their five
senses?
You know, what kind of uniform are you
wearing?
You know from that onwards.
So, when he's getting people to look at
how
detailed he's making people to think
through a problem.
Seemingly simple protocol, but in every
hotel you actually have
to come up with different answers to the
same five questions.
So, I wanna sort of give us a little bit
of time.
There are a number principles.
I won't talk about all of them.
I'm actually gonna talk about a couple of
things.
The first one is, when you scale, most of
us think that structure is the way to
coordinate.
And that certainly is useful.
But smart leaders very quickly realize
stories are actually very powerful
coordination devices.
Sometimes they're a substitute for
structure,
and other times they're a complement
to structure, and the kind of so stories
can be very powerful.
So one lovely experiment done by Laura
Boroditsky, who used to be in the
psych department here, she and her
graduate
student Peggy Thebadore did a brilliant
experiment.
So they took a large group of people like
you, randomly put you into two conditions.
And gave you one page of information that
was
completely identical about a fictional
city called Adison in California.
So they gave you about, information about
the crime rate in California.
Income, education, all these things.
There was just one difference.
People on this side of the room, they were
told that crime is lurking like a beast in
California.
And this side of the room, they said crime
is lurking like a virus in Addison City.
And they ask people, what do you think the
city of Addison oughta do?
So what do you do to a beast?
What do you do to a beast?
Kill it.
Cage it.
Slay it.
All of that.
And so when you ask people what should the
city of Addison do?
What, what did they say?
More cops, more jails, tougher
enforcement.
And by the way, this is independent of
political persuasion.
You could be a Democrat, who hates all
this, but the moment you've got this
like beast framing there in your head,
you're saying more jails, more this, more
that.
What do you do to a virus?
Treat it?
You immaculate, you cure it.
So, what should the city of Addison do?
What the city of Addison ought to do
is more counseling, more rehabilitation,
and even if you
were a fervent republican who was against
government expenditures,
you said we need to do all of this.
It's amazing, so Ben Leda and her
colleagues said, you know, maybe
we are using words like praying, what if
just use beast and virus.
Same result.
So they would use the word beast or virus
in the first two, three lines.
And they said, what happens if we do it at
the very end?
No effect.
But when you actually have a small word
like that, very quickly what
the story is doing is, all of us have
mental butlers in our heads.
And these word cues.
You instantly initiate the story telling
in your head,
and they reflect, of course, in your
political preferences.
Sometimes stories can be even more, I
mean,
the stories or cause can be even more
dramatic.
And one of the things we chronicle in our
book is about British
petroleum where the head of the retail
unit wanted to go after Shell.
And his storyline, was slam the clam.
So who's the clam?
Obvious, Shell.
So I went to him and I said, Phil, come
on, this sounds kinda hokey.
I mean, you just say slam the clam and
stuff happens?
Come on, tell me how, how does stuff
happen here?
And he said, you know, I give you that,
you might think
it's a simple little thing, but
it's extraordinarily how powerful the
effect is.
First, he said, I didn't need a slide to
get that idea across.
I just told people, slam the clam.
They got it, it stuck.
So it survived the car journey home.
Most of us listen to leaders who when they
make big announcements, you
simply sit in your car, you drive home,
you've forgotten what they said.
So this guy said, look, it survived the
car trip home.
And I said, okay, I grant you that.
What else did it do?
And he said, you know, people would sit in
a meeting,
and they would say, where should we put
new gas stations?
Ultimately, it would all come down to one
thing.
Does it slam the clam?
Where do we put advertising dollars?
Where do we put R&D dollars, where do we
hire people, anything you did, you
just had one question to actually focus
on, and that's the power of the story.
So, that's something you really ought to
think about.
The second important point I want to make
is, I want to focus on number four.
Called cut cognitive load.
So, one of the most famous articles in
Psychology is by
George Midler, it's called the Magic
Number 7, Plus or Minus 2.
And, the idea is that there are seven
things we can actually keep in our head.
And, that's the, that's what we can keep
in working
memory, that's what we can actually
process in terms of attention.
You actually increase the load to be on
seven.
What happens is, willpower is amazingly
eroded.
SO here is a lovely experiment done by Roy
Bormeester and his colleagues.
They took a large group like you and
randomly put you into two conditions.
So both groups, of course, they don't know
that the other group is there, They're
given ten math problems, and you have to
answer them, in exactly the same sequence.
Unbeknownst to the participants in the
experiment
you can only answer four of the ten.
In the ten minutes given to you.
So what they experimenters do, is they
actually tell people in this one group,
hey,
before you solve the ten math problems,
just write a two paragraph essay, some
topic.
Hypothetically, let's assume it's the City
of New York, write an essay without,
you know, but make sure you don't use
words that actually have the letters.
Z, or X, which is easy, cuz a lot of
English words don't have this particular
conjoining of the letters.
This group, the [UNKNOWN] cognitive load,
they say, write a story about
New York, but don't use the letter N and
the letter A.
That's tough, and then please solve the
math problems.
So everybody does that and the
experimenters go back to these people and
say, you know what, instead of like
getting each of your answer sheets,
physically verifying it and giving you a
dollar for each correct answer, why
don't we scream the answers, and you tell
us how many you got right.
We'll give you a buck.
But this is where the experimenters become
very clever.
So, they actually make sure in each room
there is a paper shredder.
So, they tell the participants take your
physical answer, shred it.
Nobody will know how many you got right,
and tell us how
many you think you got right, and we'll
pay you a buck.
They do this for this group as well.
Now this group that was asked to write an
essay without using the letters
N and A, how many answers do you think
they claim they got right?
And remember, you can only get four right.
The average number they claim they got
right was eight.
[LAUGH] And what about that group there?
4.75, now, because you randomly assigned
people, it's not
the dishonest people over here and honest
people over there.
You know, you've randomized with respect
to inclination towards honesty.
What happened in this room, what happened
was
they increased load, they put temptation
in their way.
What funded the temptation [INAUDIBLE] the
paper shredder.
And once you use the shredder you can tell
me how many answers you think you got
right.
I'm gonna give you a buck for every
correct answer.
For four extra bucks, basically they
cheated and they lied.
And, why is that?
It's not that people are saying, oh my God
this, this was a hard
task that's why I'm trying to get more
money out of you or something like.
When you, what is it you need to actually
resist temptation?
Will power, that's exactly right.
Most of us think will power is here, brain
power is
here, but they're actually much more
interdependent than we ever have realized.
And, what do we do in companies?
To our employees.
What do we do in terms of their brain, the
demands on their brain power?
Is that going up or going down?
Going up!
And then what do we do?
We sit and stand in front of them and say
use your will power.
You think they have any to use?
Obviously not.
And what a lot of executives therefore.
The smart ones do is they're constantly
thinking about, how do you actually lower
load?
How do you actually make sure that the
willpower kicks in?
Because, remember, excellent
organizations, you don't
need to tell people what to do.
They know what the right thing is, they'll
do it.
So, and for you as you think about your
orga, I
was just actually at a company who's name
I can't mention.
And I asked one of their executives, hey
when you had to
order laptops in your company, how many
people had to approve it?
He looked at me and said 18 approvals.
I'm thinking to myself 18 approvals.
That's a lot of approvals for a laptop
purchase.
What are most people gonna do?
They'll give up [UNKNOWN] screw the
laptop, I'm not gonna
go and get like 18 approvals to do this,
and that
giving up is the worst kind of problem
you, you can
have, so you really want to think
carefully about cognitive load.
The last thing I wanna touch on is, most
people think that going from
good to, I mean, going towards excellence
is a journey
where, you know, you just pour in good
into a system.
And that'll get you to great.
It turns out that the real thing is bad is
way more powerful than good.
In fact, a basic finding, in, psychology
is bad dominates good all the time.
See if I ask you, what are your most
powerful memories.
Bad memories rush to the forefront.
What is the most formative relationships,
bad memories
kind of quickly bad relationships surge to
the forefront.
In one study of marital couples married
couples they found
that for every nasty thing you said to
your partner
you had to at least say a minimum of five
good things to offset it you know, so you
can imagine.
Now the point is, if you don't focus on
the
bad and only focus on the good, you're in
trouble.
So, the best experiment on bad versus good
was actually
done by Philip Zimbardo here, that's the
broken windows experiment.
It wasn't some cop in New York who figured
this out.
Philip Zimbardo did a brilliant experiment
in 1969.
He took a VW, put it in Brooklyn,
broke the windows of the car, and started
filming.
And guess what?
If you see the film, you actually have a
father with
two kids, he sees the broken windows,
quickly steals the radio.
And within an hour the car's like wiped
clean, ransacked.
It's become a playground.
So, Zimbardo says, you know, maybe we
outta try the experiment in Palo Alto,
after
all Stanford University, you know, maybe
people are
better, maybe people are civic minded, et
cetera.
So, he keeps the card, people are kind of
puzzled they say hey, who's card is it.
But Zimbardo says, let me break the
windows here too.
And, you know, he breaks the windows here
too.
What do you think happens in Palo Alto?
Exactly the same thing that happened in
Brooklyn.
What do broken windows tell people?
That's exactly it.
Nobody cares, and that's what you've got
to really focus on first.
So, there's a lovely case of this Chinese
refrigerator company called Haier.
Lousy refrigerators, they were making bad,
lousy refrigerators.
what would most companies do?
Let's get black belt, blue belt, green
belt, whatever
it is, and beat you them, you know, et
cetera.
You over invest in them.
But this guy said wait a minute.
Max doing all of this statistical quality
control in
TQM, when the bathrooms the workers are
using are terrible.
That's the broken window I need to fix.
Cuz what do the lousy bathrooms tell the
workers?
Nobody cares.
And how can you ask them to care for the
customer?
So, that's where he started.
So, the real question for you is, you've
got
to always ask yourself, what is your
broken window?
And one other piece of interesting
research.
There are a number of you know, women in
the group here,
and I know the WIN folks just came in late
as well.
Particularly for women executives, the
scaling challenge is
always more likely to be from bad to
great.
And the reason is, because of something
that is called a glass cliff.
It turns out that a glass cliff is
obviously
very different than a glass ceiling and so
on.
Terms, I'm sure all of you are familiar
with.
The problem with the glass cliff is, women
are actually
given leadership opportunities where the
chance of failure is very high.
So, you know, their given actually,
precarious jobs.
Stuff to sort of succeed in these jobs,
one reason is, the men have declined them.
You know, which is one reason.
You know, they, they, the get, these jobs,
and the woman
accept them, because their not sure they
might get a second chance.
The results are experimental evidence that
suggests that people, when
they ask women to be leaders in situations
where the
performance is poor, usually when you
think of crises they
actually gravitate towards a more female
stereotype of a manager.
That's the experimental kind of evidence,
the long and short
of it is, I was, of course, giving a talk
To a group of three hundred women
executives
of course I was telling them, them this
and they said of course we know this you
know, we, we they call it the
glass cliff we've known this for a while
you know, but the challenges you always
have
to figure out how is it you're going to
start from the bad to the great.
We have I thought I'd give a little more
time for questions, but I'm a professor.
I got caught up in my own, the little
sharing of the book
idea, so pardon me for that, but if we
have time, let's take a
couple of questions, and then I'll make a
quick closing remark, and then will
you know, you can head on to wine and food
and merriment and enjoyment.
So, any questions that you might like to
ask?
>> What was about the implications from
feature expert obviously,
that might be viewed as a model, and about
scaling assets?
>> Yeah.
The fact that she was actually saying I am
not going to wait for anybody, I'll do it
myself.
That's what real excellence is.
So, you, the people who are excellent,
that's kind of what they do.
Let me, one of the heroes in our book, and
thank you for asking that question.
One of the heroes in our book is a guy
called Doug Deets.
Doug is a senior executive in GE health
care.
You go to his office he's got plaques,
awards, but that one day went to a
pediatric,
radiology section and you had young kids
afflicted
with cancer who actually were, had to have
MRIs.
And Doug sees these young children
screaming with fear.
Nearly all of them had to be sedated.
And he says, is this the kind of product
I'm making?
That's scaring young kids, and they have
to be sedated.
Parents have to entrust their seven year
old to somebody, who's going to sedate
them.
So what did Dough do?
Doug was one of the first, edition of our
customer focused innovation program.
The guy goes back spends time in,
in daycare and kindergarten, observing
young children.
And then it dawns on him and he says, oh
my God I've been stupid.
I've been developing an engineers
solution, to a childs problem of anxiety.
I need to develop a childs solution, to
the childs problem of anxiety.
And what does he do?
In the new line of, things that he's come
up with,
and he had to fight against a lot of
people in GE.
Who were saying, do we need to do this?
Do we not?
Why and where for?
So, in the new line of products, what's
amazing is, if you go to an MRI,
one of the MRI, the, the front end of the
MRI, actually looks like a space capsule.
[SOUND] So, you tell a young kid, hey.
You're going inside a space capsule.
They've forgotten it's narrow.
That it's actually claustrophobic.
You're kind of saying, you know?
Okay, that sounds cool.
So what, you know?
Another one.
There's an x-ray machine that shakes a
lot.
And, so what they've done is they've
redesigned it, as, like, the rapids.
So, they tell people, hey, you're in a
raft.
It's going to go over the rapids.
It's gonna shake like hell.
But, it's gonna be fun and, you know, they
do all these little things and
it's extraordinary what happened to
sedation rates,
they actually fell down by a large margin.
Customer satisfaction went up and, of
course, you know, processing times
improved,
then got promotions, and as we were
writing this book Bob and I.
Were on the phone with Doug.
And, you know, Doug, what's gonna happen
to you, now that you've become a VP?
And he says, no I just declined the
promotion.
I said what?
Why did you decline the promotion?
And Doug said well, I came home one day.
And my wife had just come back from a
mammogram.
And like most males, I sorta asked her,
honey, is everything okay?
Was it okay?
And Doug's wife is definitely a pistol.
So, she kinda quickly realized that Doug
needed
some serious user feedback to put it
mildly.
[LAUGH] So she looked at Doug and said.
Come, lemmi show you what it feels like.
[LAUGH] So, yeah, I know, I know.
Poor Doug, you know?
Unsuspecting Doug.
He's actually led into the garage.
She opens the garage door, and says, Doug,
put your thing out.
I'll show you what it feels like.
[LAUGH] And Doug says, oh my God.
And he, he looks at her, and says, message
received.
I actually, I'm gonna focus on this.
And that's what he's been doing for the
last year and a half.
What's he been doing?
Coming out with a new range of
mammography,
environments, where you actually can
[UNKNOWN].
And the images are much better.
You don't need to face the excruciating
pain, pressure, all of
these kinds of things that a lot of people
go through.
So, when I think of that young school
teacher, it's like,
you don't wait for people to tell you what
to do.
You do sort of what you need to.
Yes, please.
Right there.
>> You talked a little earlier about the
premortem.
>> Yeah.
>> As an idea, where people kinda write
down how they would fail.
>> Mm-hm, or how they would succeed, too.
>> Yes, how do you prevent the people
who write the failure condition from
freaking out?
[LAUGH] Or you know, maybe fulfilling the
prophecy themselves?
>> so, that's a reasonable question.
So what you want is you want to stimulate
their imagination, but you don't
want to arouse their anxiety is kind of
the other way you put it.
So, what you have to do is you
actually have to give them reasonably
detailed instructions
that serve as kind of mental scaffolding,
so they're not gonna go off the deep end.
So, what you want is you actually, so for
instance, you would say, here's a story
that you, when
you fail, this is the kind of story that's
gonna feature in the pages of NYT or
whatever magazine.
And then you say, write a story.
And when you write a story, you actually
give them a page limit.
You know, so you, you don't need to go on
and on.
And you tell them you can write the story
any way you want.
You can write it as a memo.
You can write it as whatever, but it has
to be a story and not a list.
And usually what people do is they
actually give pretty granular kinds of
accounts.
Now, I found that the stories of failure.
Or actually little more concrete than
stories
of success, and the reason you need
to do both is, what causes failure may be
quite different from what causes success.
It's not like there are five factors, high
on
everything success, low on everything
failure you know, it doesn't
work like that, you know life's too
complicated to work
like that, and, so you have to take those
things.
You then have to put them together, and
then
you have to analyze what the common themes
are.
I usually like to after reading when I
work with companies, I
usually gather all these premortem, and I
present them not in the
sense of, like you know, so many people
said this or that,
but you present them more in the visual of
a downward spiral.
And then an upward spiral, people say oh
my God, that's where we need to start
earning.
>> Do the same people write both stories?
>> No, you have to actually, cuz once
you've imagined one thing,.
It's hard to reimagine the other, so you,
you
got to make it random and not say, well,
let me go to the optimist and let me go to
the pessimist and that kind of thing.
You don't want to do all that.
Just make it random, one page, and
anonymous, independent, they
actually ask, you can actually get a lot
of useful things.
By the way, you might wanna do that if
you're thinking of taking new jobs, too.
So you should really do a pre-mortem of
the job and ask the person hiring you,
or if you're the person hiring somebody,
you
know, you can actually do this sort of
interchanging.
Cuz that's really what you wanna negotiate
about,
not simply how much you're gonna be paid.
Cuz everything's about the runway.
Is it a short runway, is it a long runway,
how to prepare the runway.
One more question please.
Then we're gonna be, out of time.
Yep.
>> I read Marty Seligman's book which
references
the five to one ratio for couples, and he
also talks about how there's a three to
one
ratio for organizations, of positive
comments to negative comments.
So I've implemented this in my
organization, but one of
the questions that I've always had is, if
people in meetings
sit around telling each other how
fantastic they are, then there
can be a demotivating effect of basically
being average or okay.
So is there any experimental evidence of
a, of a top side to that
ratio of when organizations are too
positive
and the employees don't feel enough
motivation?
>> That's an excellent question.
I think what you don't want to do is, you
know, Seligman's view, of course, is it's
all about positive thinking and positive
emotion and there's
certainly quite a bit to kinda recommend
about that.
But if you only give people information
about what is it
that they're good at and you don't talk
about their failure.
Clearly, you're giving them biased
information, and paradoxically, that very
bias
in the information, causes people to
discount the usefulness of it.
So, what you want to give people is, the
way I sort
of think about it is, it's not feed back
but feed forward.
So it's not like what did you do well or
what did you do poorly.
What is it you need to do in the future?
Cuz, you know, a little bit of the
rearview glass is a useful thing, but
you gotta get them to think what is it
they're going to do in the future?
And you know, I think when you think of
the negative things.
Here the important thing, of course, is
not
to fall prey to the fundamental
attribution adder.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
the number is too high?
>> Uh-huh.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah.
I don't think that there's kind of upper
bound if that's kind of what you're
referring to.
Our interest of course, in the bad being
stronger than good
is I sort of think of that as a nice
study.
That tells you how potent bad is and why
you need to pay attention to it.
I think a lot of it is also quite honestly
the kinds of people you hire.
I was actually with the CEO recently and I
said, what's your secret of hiring?
How do you scale excellence?
And he says, well, I try and actually look
for
people who are tougher on themselves than
I am on them.
I don't need to micromanage it.
Then I can put an arm around them, you
know.
Now the catch is, how do you find those
people?
And sometimes you can find them in the
oddest of spaces.
One lovely story I heard from a hedge fund
executive in New York
was I said, how do you hire people at,
the, the entry level?
You get to like Math jocks and you know,
so forth, or whizzes
and so on and so forth, or how do you go
about doing it?
He says, no, we actually aim to hire
athletes from the best university.
I said, athletes, like, exactly what does
that tell you?
He looked at me and he said, the great
thing about athletes from the
best universities, is they may not be
eventually succeed in terms of a
professional career.
But they have two amazing characteristics.
The first thing is, these athletes have an
incredible capacity to do repetitive work.
Hundred meter swim.
Do it again.
They can do that for a long period of
time.
The other, the, the other thing he said,
which was like
a brilliant line was, he said they're the
most open to feedback.
They can be coached.
Cuz what do you do if you're an athlete?
You get the hundred meters.
And then you sorta look at the coach and
say, what did I do wrong?
Where'd I, what do I need to fix?
So he said, that's why we need to, we hire
people like that.
Cuz.
They're actually craving that feedback.
But they keep, keep on doing the
repetitive work.
And they're not all thinking they wanna be
you know
running the company you know, imminently
soon or whatever it is.
So it's 6:15.
My hope is this has been useful to you.
And you wanna actually think of.
You know, taking some of these ideas about
scaling excellence.
So as you scale them and if you have a
chance to read the
book, by all means please write to me with
questions, stories, and the like.
That's how at least I get educated.
But I want to close with one little story
hopefully that kind of inspires you a
little bit.
And that is some, sometimes when you
have to scale excellence, you don't have
resources.
You don't have money, you don't have the
people, you
don't have all these things, how do you do
that?
And a great example of that is this chain
here called Cost Plus World
Market, in California, when the CEO took
over the company, the stock was I
think at a buck and a half a share, when
he sold it to
Bed, Bath and Beyond I think he sold it
for twenty two dollars a share.
So I asked Barry, I said, Barry, how did
you turn this place around?
I said, did you pay out big bonuses?
He said, can't do that, no money to do
that.
Did you hire great people?
Can't do that.
Did you train them?
He said, how can I train people?
We sell, you know, jam from Sweden to
handy crafts from Kenya
to whatever, nobody can have all the
product knowledge, it's too complicated.
So, I said, what did you do?
And he said like, well, we figured out
that the real task is to
get people to buy more than one thing when
they walk into a store.
So I said, what did you do?
Did you have an incentive program?
The more people bought, the more people
got paid?
He said no.
I said, what if you do, then?
He said, we told our employees to do two
things.
When a customer walks in, smile.
And the second thing is, when a customer
walks in, give him or her a basket.
That's it.
That's what you need to do.
Because the moment you give them a basket,
the probability
of them purchasing more than one product
has shot up substantially.
Then I'm gonna just buy one thing.
They'll probably buy three things.
It was the most effective thing that we
did, he said.
And my question to you, as you're thinking
about scaling up excellence in
your own respective organizations is,
what's the equal end of your basket?
So think about that.
It's 6:15, I'm out of time.
Thank you so very much.
[SOUND] Thank you.
[MUSIC]